[Music]
what you're looking at is the work of
digital artists zack hadel and michael
cusack
this piece that's part of their explore
collection sold for over 20
thousand dollars but the art doesn't
live as an animation in a gallery
it lives on the blockchain pieces like
this are part of a growing asset class
called
nfts or non-fungible tokens a unique
token on a blockchain that houses the
ownership of whatever is attached to it
if you swapped a bitcoin for another
bitcoin both which are fungible tokens
you just have another bitcoin but with
nfts each one is unique and that a
specific item is attached to it
say you traded two nfts connected to art
you would have two completely different
pieces that would be swapped for one
another
the values of which could vary
differently the way i like to explain
nfts is that
nfts are just a better type of digital
item
than the digital items that we've seen
in the past a good example of a digital
item is
a movie that you bought on itunes if
itunes decides to delete your account or
delete the movie then
your movie is gone so that's how digital
items used to work
nfts are the first sort of digital item
that work the way that we
expect stuff to work where if i own an
nft from an artist
and that artist decides to quit or stop
making work then i still own that nft
and i could you know take that nft and
lock it up in a safe
so an nft is just like a new type of
digital item a digital item that we can
really own
that's duncan cockfoster co-founder of
nifty gateway who along with his brother
griffin have created a platform for
artists to create and sell digital art
with
just an account and a credit card the
company gained enough attention to get
bought out by the winklevoss twins
crypto exchange gemini in 2019
and it's not just visual artists that
are incorporating the technology
the nba announced its top shot lines of
crypto collectibles has generated 230
million in sales so far
popular rock band kings of leon
announced their next album will be
released as an nft
and just recently grimes sold 6 million
dollars worth of her digital art
featuring videos set to music but mixing
the world of art and money
always leads to caution for traditional
auction houses
forgeries and fakes still fall through
the cracks
duncan thinks trades through nfts keep
authenticity
clear some people will try and create
fake nfts
where maybe they'll take a work mark
from from nifty gateway and mint to new
nft using that work of art
but it's actually pretty simple to
discover that the nft did not come from
nifty gateway
and instead is a is a fake so while it
is a problem
it's it's much easier to design tools to
uh
to counteract it because nfts can be
instantly and
and perfectly authenticated which just
isn't the case for physical art so
why are so many people flocking to nfts
if it's a digital asset and the picture
alone is available to copy and paste
wherever you'd like
what's the point in purchasing many in
the space are purchasing
simply to normalize the sale of digital
art in hopes that it brings back money
to artists
and others do it for the same reason we
collect traditional art
the bragging rights to say i own an
authentic piece from an artist
and maybe hoping that the piece we
bought quadruples and price down the
road
we already have a situation in the
physical art world where people can
create
perfect physical reproductions but
they're not actually valuable at all
the only thing that gives art value is
the authenticity and the artist
basically saying
yes i certified this work is authentic
and i certified that i only made
10 editions and then those additions are
what becomes valuable
so it's actually not that different from
what already exists in the physical art
world it's just happening for digital
art the method of authentication is a
blockchain token that
people can own and send across the world
instantly
with traditional auction houses
revamping for an online world
they've taken notice of the nft trade as
well christie's announced its first
auction of solely digital artwork from
popular artist people
and like anything dealing with the
blockchain the enthusiasm seems to only
be going up
um i i honestly think in five to ten
years people will probably spend more on
nfts than they do on
on physical art just the same way that
uber you know greatly increased the
money that people spend on
transportation by
by making it more available for them to
get places
i think nfts make art collecting far
more accessible
and that will actually increase the
total size of the art market
[Music]